hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar viral evolution and implications
on hiv and sars covi2
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott
to learn more visit abbott.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
mary rogers principal research scientist
at abbott
mary you may now begin your presentation
thank you marie and thank you to
everyone who's dialed in and uh watching
this presentation today um it's my
pleasure to be able to share what we
know about viral evolution and the
implications it has for both hiv and
sars code 2.
so let's start at the beginning
of the hiv pandemic back in the 1980s
and we'll look at some parallels between
that time and where we are now with the
starscope 2 pandemic
so back in 1985 abbott was there we had
the first fda approved test for hiv at a
time when even the name of the virus
hadn't really been locked down you can
see our test was actually called htlv3
um in that picture on the right and that
was because the virus name was changing
a lot and that's kind of a theme we're
living with uh in the current stars cos2
pandemic as well
but what's the same about both the time
in 1985 at the beginning of the hiv
pandemic and today with starscope 2
is that
diagnostic tests were and are urgently
needed to fight the pandemic they're the
first prong of our defense against any
pandemic threat out there and it's
really important that our diagnostic
tests are working
and if we fast forward to where we are
with hiv today
we'll see that diagnostic tests remain
key to ending the hiv pandemic in the
united states
so some key facts from the cdc are that
we know that undiagnosed people living
with hiv account for over a third of all
new cases of hiv
so that means that people who don't know
they have hiv yet who are undiagnosed
are driving a significant proportion of
new infections
we look at how many people out there
don't know that they have hiv there's
one in seven people who don't know that
they have hiv and and that's something
we need to change
so if we look at our approach for how to
end hiv there's four main pillars and
the the first one that's required for
all the rest of them to be successful um
to be able to treat people to be able to
prevent and to be able to respond we
need diagnostics as a focal point to
make sure that we know who's positive
and we know who's been exposed and who
might need to be treated so
this is key today as much as it ever has
been as we still have 38 million people
living with hiv today
so
what about viral diversity so that's the
title of the talk today and i want to
talk a little bit more about what that
means in the first place and why it's
important so viral diversity is
important for diagnostic tests and for
blood screening tests
for a major reason and that's because
all of our tests rely fundamentally on
something being the same in every
positive sample so whether it's a
molecular test a mutation in the binding
region of a primer or probe could
potentially mean you could miss
detection or under quantify a result
because of that mutation which just
comes as a result of viral diversity
and likewise tests that are in serology
space that are detecting a viral protein
antigen or antibodies directed towards
that antigen are prone to impact from
any sequence changes there as well since
any
anything that changes this structure
really will impact a serology test
and so if we look at the scope of the
problem with viral diversity we'll see
that hiv is particularly divergent
compared to other viruses
so if we plot all of the strains of
these given categories on a phylogenetic
tree which is something where the
the distance between two points on the
tree are proportional to how different
they are from each other
we see that on the same scale
all of the global strains from one year
for influenza are on the same scale of
diversity that we find in just one hiv
patient over the course of six years of
their infection
and then if we expand our view moving to
the right to hiv one subtype b in just
one city we see that the magnitude of
that diversity has increased even
further
and then if we expand our view to the
farthest on the right to the democratic
republic of congo group m strains
that's where we see a significant amount
of diversity knowing that democratic
republic of congo is one of the parts of
the world where the hiv pandemic first
took a global stage and really expanded
to become
the disease that we live with worldwide
today
and so if we expand our phylogenetic
tree for hiv even further
we'll see that group n which was the
biggest one on the last slide is
actually just one part of an even larger
phylogenetic tree
and that's important because when we
look at
each of these branches they have enough
sequence difference that it could have
major impacted diagnostic tests
an illustration of this is if you
compare the envelope sequence of a
strain that's on the left hand side
with the letter b by the branch in group
m
to the envelope region in a group o
strain over on the right hand side of
the tree they only share 50 similarity
and that's the part of the virus that
changes the most um but it's also the
one that the region that our antibodies
are most likely to respond to so
we have to be monitoring it and make
sure that our diagnostic tests are built
so that they can detect either one with
one single test result
so you can see that there's non-human
primates pictured next to each of these
major four groups of hiv on the tree and
that's because the siv or um
simian immunodeficiency viruses that are
the closest ancestors to the human
hiv strains in each of those branches
are from different species of non-human
primates and so um there's always a
branch that we may not know about we're
always concerned about whether there's a
new line coming off of this tree from a
new cross species transmission event
since there are 45 different primate
species worldwide there's always that
potential risk for this to happen again
and we need to be aware and monitoring
doing surveillance to remain vigilant in
looking for those new strains that could
potentially arise
so
hiv diversity is pretty broad and
there's a few different reasons for that
diversity um evolution is occurring all
the time and there's three main
uh reasons behind that the first is the
different starting points that i
mentioned earlier that there were
actually different viruses from
different non-human primates like
chimpanzees gorillas or [ __ ] mangabees
that were responsible for the
transmission to humans to cause hiv and
so those different starting points were
a different sequence in the first place
so that's the first source of genetic
diversity for hiv
the second source are the mistakes that
the virus makes it replicates and
incorporates incorporates a mistake
pretty frequently
so that it if it can't actually repair
those mistakes which hiv does not code
any mechanism for repairing mistakes
that it makes those mutations just get
propagated into new strains
and then the last mechanism are the new
recombinations so i have an illustration
at the bottom of the slide of how
recombination events occur and so if
someone is infected with two different
strains of hiv shown in red and green
here
those strains have the ability to
shuffle and recombine so that you result
with a mosaic virus that has bits and
pieces of the first two strains in a
different organization or pattern
so that part of the genome is closely
related to one strain but not to another
and vice versa
and so the position of these break
points where recombination has occurred
can be similar in non-transmission
linked cases if it spreads to multiple
regions of the world and so when that
happens we call it a circulating
recombinant form because it's
circulating and it's now becoming common
however we're also seeing a lot of
unique recombinant forms and those are
ones where there's really just one
transmission chain of cases that are
linked to that particular breakpoint
pattern
super context there's actually over a
hundred different crfs that are
recognized worldwide today and if we
look in surveillance of hiv we'll see
just as many if not probably ten times
more unique recombinant forms that are
found worldwide
so let's take a look at what the strains
are in different parts of the world so
we know that in the united states
subtype b is the predominant strain but
it really only represents 12 of
infections worldwide and you can see on
this map that there's no part of the
world that's just one color we have
multiple strains in every part of the
world and we know that each of these
frames is a plane right away in this
globally connected world so we need to
monitor strains all around the world to
make sure that our tests can detect an
infection regardless of where it occurs
and you can see that some parts of the
world have a lot more
slices in the pie so if you look in
central africa where hiv first emerged
and where the cross species transmission
events effective occurred
you can see that all colors are present
and that also reflects that as the part
of the world where the origins lie
if we take another look at the united
states specifically we're seeing
increasing diversity here as well so we
predominantly have subtype b but that's
changing over time we're starting to see
more crfs and urs and other subtypes
present in the united states and it's
not just one part of the country it's
really everywhere that we're seeing this
rise in diversity for hiv
and we really never truly know where the
next strain of hiv will show up and an
illustration of this is a case that
occurred not too long ago um with a
woman who uh
started living in france after moving
from cameroon in 2004
and she was diagnosed as hiv positive
with a western blot which will detect
that she has antibodies and since hiv
infection is lifelong if someone has
antibodies they typically have viral rna
as well and their viral load at that
time was one of the indicators of
whether someone should go on treatment
so
um when they went to detect the viral
load that she had um surprisingly she
was negative on the monitor version 1.5
viral load test and this is unusual
since
in every part of the world that has been
examined less than half a percent of
people can naturally control hiv without
taking medication
so they went on to test a few other time
points that were sampled from her and
they found that between four and five
log copies per ml were detected by the
avid m2000 real-time viral load test
so there was virus present
and circulating in her body and then she
was also positive on the abbott
architect combo test in this research
study
so the group wanted to understand why
there were discordant test results
because that typically is a red flag
that maybe there's a new strain of virus
present when one test is detecting it
and another test does not and so the
group used the primers for the known
groups of hiv at the time which were
only group m and group o
and they wanted to be able to sequence
to determine if she had any resistance
to
any of the options that were available
for treatment at the time but those
primers didn't work because the sequence
was so different and so they decided to
use less specific primers and went on to
use siv
specific primers and they were able to
get an entire viral genome sequence and
it was one of those strains that was
really far out there on that big
phylogenetic tree that i showed earlier
this was the first case of group p and
it had origins in gorillas that carried
the closest related strain to this group
p
so we saw this paper here at abbott in
our surveillance program when it was
published and we went back into our
sample repository
and screened our samples from cameroon
and found the second known case of group
p that's ever been found to date
these studies came out around 2009-2011
and since then these still are the only
two cases of group p it's not a very
common form of hiv but it's out there
and it's circulating so it's important
to make sure that tess can detect it
so um in comparison i'll just give a
brief um
viewpoint of startup code 2
where you can look at the phytogenetic
diversity of sars code 2 and it looks
like it's a diverse virus because we
have all of these variants and there's
different streams in different parts of
the world similar to hiv but i'd like to
point out that in this example here
which comes from neckstrain.org which is
an excellent resource for understanding
source code 2
and how it's evolving
this tree is resolved by time and so the
actual differences and distances between
the branches are actually much smaller
than they appear in this tree um
sarcostu really shares over 99
nucleotide identity between the
different strains um in the majority of
sequences around the world so when we
hear that there's 30 mutations or 50
mutations you always keep in mind that
there's 30 000 nucleotides in the full
genome of stars code 2. so if we look on
the scale of overall viral diversity hiv
still ranks pretty high where different
subtypes differ by about
ten percent as opposed to less than one
percent for stars code two
so um
avid is meeting the challenge of viral
diversity with our abbott global
surveillance program
this is a program that we started over
25 years ago and our goal is to study
hepatitis and retrovirus variation with
collaborators that we work with in
countries all around the world so that
we can understand which strains are
circulating
we added source code 2 to the program in
2020 and it continues on today
we're monitoring the emergence of new
viral strains for these viruses which as
we've all lived through this past
weekend as the newest stars co2 variant
emerged omicron
this can happen at any time and so we
need to remain vigilant
we then take the samples that we
sequenced through our program and use
them to establish well-characterized
specimen panels that represent all the
viral genotypes and common mutations
from a broad geographical um viewpoint
for regulatory submissions and for
really challenging all of our diagnostic
tests here at abbott
so there's several benefits from this
program the first being that we're
actually using the circulating strains
that are out there as the ongoing basis
for all of our assay development here at
abbott
and we're able to provide assays that
reliably detect and monitor all
infections regardless of where they
occur
and we've been sharing our knowledge
with the world at large we have been
publishing over the whole course of the
program we're up to over 140
peer-reviewed publications today and
we've deposited thousands of viral
sequences into public databases so that
they can be used um not just to study
diagnostics but to help with vaccine
development and therapeutics and so on
so to date we're at over 83 000 samples
that we have collected throughout the
duration of our program and these have
come from 45 different countries on six
continents and if you're wondering which
countries are included i'll show you the
map
so since the beginning of the program we
added a couple of sites a year and grew
to the map that you see here today where
each country has a dot
and in the past several years about five
or six years we've really increased
really picked up the pace and increased
our footprint around the world with
these additional green dots and all
these countries shown here we've also
started to add more blood banks to our
programs recognizing that to keep the
blood supply safe we really need to
specifically be looking at strains that
are found in um
potential blood donations coming from
blood donors and so with this in mind
we've been able to collect and work with
our collaborators to publish all these
papers and characterize all of these
strains of viruses um for hiv and and
i'll talk about stars cove too in second
half of the talk
but ultimately this has allowed us to
build
really a one-of-a-kind viral diversity
panel for hiv
and so i'm listing here all of the
geographies at the bottom of the
um slide all the countries that are
included in this diversity panel as well
as all of the classifications of hiv
that are included in the panel
i'd like to highlight that in addition
to the group m strains on the left hand
side of the screen
we've also been the group that's
discovered 11 out of 17 known group n
infections that have ever been
characterized and sequenced and those
are our sequences that are out there in
genbank
we've also as i mentioned earlier have
discovered one of two known group p
infections and we have over 200 kubo
infections at this point that we've
sequenced and characterized
so i also have an arrow next to a
subtype that might not be as familiar to
people on the line it's the newest
subtype of hiv called subtype l
and i'll be sharing a little bit more
information about how that subtype came
to be in a few slides when i talk about
the democratic republic of congo
so i'd love to be able to tell you about
our collaborations in all 46 countries
but today i'm going to focus on three of
them
that will illustrate how we do this work
to understand viral diversity for hiv
and hepatitis viruses
so the first one is the democratic
republic of congo and this is the place
where we are working for decades really
um with our collaborator dr carol
macarthur
who is based at university of missouri
kansas city and leads a group at
university protestant of congo in
kinshasa and she has been working to
provide a free hiv test to people who
need it in kinshasa and then sending the
leftover samples both positive and
negative to us for sequencing so that we
can understand whether there's any new
strains present and look at the
diversity that's there
and so we've identified a lot of
different strains um i'll talk about l
in a moment
that's highlighted in red there but
beyond those subtypes we've also found a
lot of crfs and some very complex urs so
if you look at the plot on the right
underneath the map this is a walk
through the genome from left to right
and different colors represent different
classifications so you can see that
there's recombination all over this
genome lots of complex recombination
events that have occurred multiple
times with multiple strains
through multiple co-infections and so
we're seeing more and more complex
recombinants like this the more we
sequence full genomes
from democratic republic of congo and
from frankly every country that we do
our work in
so in addition to the complex
recombinants we've also sequenced some
crfo1 genomes through this study and
we've done a little bit of extra work on
these to understand how they fit into
the molecular history of the hiv
pandemic in asia where crfo1 is one of
the predominant strains
so um we've been working with dr tullio
de oliveira and edwin wilkinson at
university of kwazulu-natal crisp and
their new institution in stellenbosch
which is called siri
and in this study we took some of the
crfo1 genomes that we had characterized
from the democratic republic of congo
and added them to the global tree for
crf01 we found that this was a new link
between the oldest sequences that came
from central africa that were used to
date the origin of cfo1 all the way back
to the early 1970s
and then these strains came next that
came from our studies in drc in cameroon
and
they're the link between those african
strains and the
asian strains that are
colored in blue in this plot above and
so this is really interesting because
cfo one is a recombinant of subtype a
which is commonly found
in many geographies and subtype e which
has never really been sequenced as a
complete genome it's an unusual sequence
that's found in just cfo1 strain and so
we've always been trying to understand
better what the origin of genotype or
subtype e really is and the more we
understand about 0 1 the more we can
learn about where e really is and and
how it fits in to the whole history of
hiv
so
in addition to the crfo1 genomes we've
also identified a new subtype called
subtype l
and so in this part of the project
this really began in 2001 when a
specimen was collected in central
democratic republic of congo
by carol's group and the sample made its
way here to abbott
where we were able to
determine that the viral load was pretty
low it was less than four log
copies per ml which is making it makes
it very challenging to sequence a
complete genome so we did sub genomic
sequencing initially and we saw that
with just small regions of the genome we
actually could tell right away that it
didn't really seem to
be related to most strains that are
circulating today it seemed very
divergent and so we worked on developing
techniques that would allow us to get a
complete genome
next generation sequencing technology
and this part of the project was really
driven by my colleague dr mike berg who
developed an hiv smart method for
specifically sequencing hiv
but unfortunately that first attempt
gave us low genome coverage so he took
it a step further and developed an
enrichment method called xgen that has
probes space throughout the hiv genome
that cover the full diversity that we
know of to date
and specifically pulls out
uh the hiv reads before sequencing on an
aluminum
instrument and so using that method um
sequencing was done by my colleague
julie yamaguchi and she found that
throughout the entire length of the
genome you can see on the right in
recombinant analysis that there really
was no other strain present this was a
pure sequence
without any recombination from other
subtypes or classifications
and when
we plotted it on a phylogenetic tree we
saw that it was really only related to
two other sequences that were in public
repositories the first one was sequenced
from a patient in the 1980s and another
was sequenced from a patient in the
1990s
but
both of them were also found in the
democratic republic of congo which means
that although this is a very rare strain
it is completely unique from all the
other subtypes and it met the criteria
for defining a new subtype which really
is the first um set of sequences that
have met that criteria since the
guidelines were even established in 2000
um to define the subtypes the other
subtypes that are on the tree that you
see here
and so this was um pretty surprising to
us that this we're still learning more
and more about hiv even 30 years
40 years really plus since
the pandemic really began um so
we're continuing our work obviously to
look at hiv diversity in this part of
the world and and all of our sites
really for surveillance knowing that we
could still be finding new strains of
this virus
so we'll shift gears to um another
aspect of the study that wasn't
necessarily viral diversity and it kind
of took us by surprise as well so in the
same study where we were looking at
samples from people who had
been tested for hiv we saw that there
were a lot of samples that had
discordant test results and if you
remember from earlier that's usually a
sign that there could be a divergent
virus present and so um we really wanted
to understand
why we were seeing this result so in the
plot below
our testing algorithm you can see that
there were a number of samples that
clustered around the y-axis where they
were positive on our serology test hiv
combo but they were not detectable for
viral load and so this again is very
unusual because typically if people are
not on medication they can't naturally
suppress hiv and in studies conducted
around the world including other
countries in africa the prevalence of
people who can naturally control hiv is
less than half a percent
so we set out to rule out other
explanations we were very consistently
looking for another way to explain this
we even had the samples tested on
another viral load assay um and they
were still negative with another test we
um did metagenomic sequencing that's not
specific for hiv so that if there was a
divergent string present we should find
it we didn't um the we looked at the
integrity of the sample to see if maybe
there was degradation but we were able
to seek when hepatitis c virus from
samples like this and no problem so we
know that there was intact virus if
there
wasn't someone who was able to control
it and then we did also test some
samples and rule out uh whether people
were on treatment so after excluding all
those other possible explanations we
came down to a range of about 2.7 to 4.3
percent of all patients with hiv in our
study going back all the way to 1987 i
should point out so those different
colored dots are because we are sampling
from
uh studies going back from 1987 to 2003
and 2017 to 2019.
so this is a consistent rates that we're
seeing over time and when you think
about how many people have hiv in
kinshasa and drc at large this
translates to hundreds of people
and we really see this study as a
springboard to alert the scientific
community that perhaps instead of
looking at one or two hiv controllers
that come through other studies
where they're less commonly found
perhaps we could be learning more from
this really unique larger group of
people in kinshasa
naturally controlling hiv
all right so um if we move along to
another one of our program sites in our
collaboration with yrg care in india
we'll see that we're looking a little
bit differently with more of a public
health um aspect to our work um and
we're collaborating with dr sunil
solomon who heads up this
institution called yrg care based in
chennai india
that provides health care to
marginalized communities in india and in
particular our study focused on people
who inject drugs or a few words
um sunil is also a professor at john
copkins university and an epidemiologist
so we looked at this data set through
the lens of understanding the
unique aspects around
serving this population in india
so we took samples like our previous
study and sequenced them for people who
were co-infected with hiv and hcv
and you can see from the distribution of
colors in the different plots from five
cities in india there's a big difference
here between hiv and hcb diversity in
india
there's pretty homogeneously mostly
subtype c for hiv that's the purple that
you see although we did see some
recombinants that were unique in
different regions of the country where
um strains were
recombinant with
the strains that are found in the drug
trafficking rods in neighboring
countries
but then if you look at hcv you can see
that there's a lot of diversity and it
seems to differ which strains are
predominating depending on which part of
the country is shown so there's a lot of
diversity there um and this is coming
from a
fairly large number we have over 1900
sequences that were included in this
study
and so we published this last year and
since then have taken it a step further
so sunil's group
has gone on to do cluster analysis with
the sequences from the hpv and hiv
infections and i think when you look at
what the clusters look like even just
visually here you can tell that they're
very different between the viruses and
that tells us that the transmission
networks are quite different between
these viruses so if you look at the hiv
clusters there's
most of them are just two people there's
fewer of those multi-person clusters and
you see the colors represent the
different cities that were in the study
all of the clusters have the same color
there's no cross city transmission going
on
but then if you contrast that to the hcv
clusters you see that there's a lot of
different cities represented in each of
these clusters and
some of them are pretty big
with a lot of people included in that
transmission chain and so this has told
us a lot about how these different
viruses are spreading in this population
and it tells us that we need to take
this into consideration that people are
traveling a lot and so any
initiatives that are in place to try and
treat and prevent infections have to be
aware of the travel and
approaches that need to come into play
for people who are in multiple cities
and so now we'll move on to the last um
hiv vignette here in one of the
countries we've been working in the
longest which is cameroon um and this is
work we've done with dr nicos modemby dr
dora mabana and the late professor kept
chewie
who we've been working with all the way
back into the 90s at the beginning of
the program
and so this is a study that we did um
over the course of several years in
southern cameroon where we focused on
testing through a number of channels in
the towns and villages in the areas of
the country that are closest to the
actual natural habitats of the animals
that carry the closest relatives to hiv
so these yellow and green dots represent
the locations of the animals that carry
the closest relatives
um to group n glucose
and so there's this is where there's
always potential for new cross-species
transmission events
and where we need to always keep a close
eye on new strains that might be
emerging
and so if you look at the diversity of
the strains we've detected here you can
see that we have a lot of subtypes here
as well a lot of crfs but a little bit
different from the other sites we're
actually seeing some of those rare
groups group o and group n strains have
been found in this study
we've also looked at htlv and found the
fifth known case of htlv3 in this study
and a unique ae recombinant of hepatitis
b
so we are seeing a lot of diversity in
everywhere that we look frankly because
these viruses are highly divergent
both hiv hepatitis c and i didn't have
time to talk a lot about hepatitis b
today but we're also monitoring that one
as well
so
um one of the main themes that we're
seeing here is that it's taken us
years to learn everything we know about
hiv today and we're still continuing to
learn about hiv today and um as we know
there's still a lot to learn about sars
cove too and so i'd like to spend the
next section of the talk going over what
we know about sars code 2 and the
diversity and challenges that represent
for diagnostic tests
so it's important to understand a little
bit about the nomenclature of stars cove
too because i think hearing these
different lineages in the news can get
kind of confusing if you don't have a
foundation of what they come from
so when the guidelines were first
established for stars cove to
nomenclature there were only 81 lineages
to begin with and that's shown here in
the image on the right this is the
phylogenetic tree and it shows that each
of the names that are given to the
different strains of stars code 2
that have a letter and a series of
numbers um and they represent an actual
branch on the phylogenetic tree because
they represent a specific outbreak
that's all related to each other
and so now there's well over a thousand
there's over 1500 um and this is
constantly changing some lineages are
being consolidated or renamed over and
over again
but you can see at the top that the
oldest um part of the tree started with
the letter a
and then the tree grew to have strains
that start with the letter b
and this is just continued through the
alphabet as we see more and more strains
evolving
but a lineage number is only assigned if
four criteria are met that there's at
least one
nucleotide difference from the parental
strain there has to be at least five
genomes that are similar and they have
to have at least one common mutation and
they have to have enough phylogenetic
bootstrap support so the tree has to
have high enough
statistical analysis for at least 70
percent of all trees have them grouped
together
so ultimately that's what it looks like
on the phylogenetic scale but what this
has turned into is a continually
evolving nomenclature system with the
latest um whole labels added to
designate strains that are of particular
interest or concern
and so i've listed on the left the
lineages that are in that phylogenetic
tree version which are
um representing unique outbreak strains
and then the list of the earliest
documented geographies where those were
first down which doesn't necessarily
mean that's where they came from but
that's where they were first detected or
sequenced
and then the whole label and omicron
came up too quickly i don't have it on
this table but
it does have
mutations that we're tracking in our
surveillance program
and so on the right i've highlighted the
nucleotide mutations in each of these
strains because i think ultimately
that's what's important here um
the mutations themselves are what define
each of these strains but even so you
can see that in one of the proteins of
the virus that's really key for
diagnostics nucleocapsid is a target for
anagen tests
you can see that three of these
variant lineages beta epsilon and mu
have the exact same nucleotide sequence
for nucleotide they just have one
mutation at position t205 to i
um the rest of the genome differs
obviously but if we're looking at how
well conserved nuclear capsid is it's
actually a pretty well conserved part of
the virus and so we just need between
one and four mutations
it's also worth noting that for delta
as more and more strains are identified
in that category of delta some have
different flavors so i highlighted g215c
in purple here because um that was one
that was only in some of the delta
strains and not all of them so these
even though they're all called delta
they're kind of a homogeneous
or heterogeneous rather mixture of
strains
and you can see that in this
illustration here that i put together
where we walk through the different
names of some of the strains as they
emerge that are all in kind of the delta
realm
so the first one had a lineage
assignment of
b1617.1 and the whl calls this kappa
and it was first sequenced in india and
you can see the mutation profile that
has been pulled from outbreak.info which
is a great website if you're looking for
a resource to see what mutations are
present in any of these lineages we're
talking about
so the next strain um has the same name
except it's dot two instead of that one
but this one is delta and it has a lot
more mutations as you look across the
genome you can just visually see that
there's a lot of mutations that
differentiate kappa from delta even
though the lineage numbers only differ
by one
and then if you look at the bottom there
you'll see that there's another strain
that originally was called v1617.2.1
but then was renamed to ay1 so that's
where this is constantly kind of
influxed as we learn more about
sequences and where they're found
but this is where we're seeing um that
there really are only two
positions that change between
b1617.2 and ay1 which is interesting
because that's not very many changes
when you think about everything we just
saw for hiv
so what are we doing here at abbott to
understand um source code two variants
so there's a lot of things we're working
on to make sure we're vigilant in
understanding how our tests perform for
all of the many virus strains that are
out there for stars code 2 that includes
epitope mapping for our tests like our
antigen tests doing in silico analysis
i'll tell you over the weekend i spent a
lot of time looking at omicron to
understand how
mutations look compared to our target
regions of all of our abbot tests in the
rdrp nucleotide and spike regions
and then we also make recombinant
antigen for tests that we want to
understand what
might impact um our performance of
anagen tests and we're also able to put
culture viruses here in our labs um and
that's led up by my colleague dr mike
fur
but what i'd like to really focus on in
the last part of the talk here are the
sequence clinical samples from our
surveillance program where we're working
with collaborators around the us and
around the world on four continents
so whenever we're looking at the
performance of diagnostic tests for
variants i think it's really key to keep
in mind that there's a lot of challenges
finding the right sample to test in the
first place i've highlighted leftover
clinical samples here because that's
what we're characterizing here in our
surveillance program
but there's always caveats around that
you never really can control for how
many times a sample has been frozen and
thawed and some people are collecting
samples and inactivating them which
completely disrupts the nuclear captive
protein and renders it impossible to
detect with a
antigen test
and virus cultures are good because we
can control how much virus is there but
we're also trying to understand how to
standardize virus culture measurements
in particular the units for how much you
have in a sample
and antibody specimens are the hardest
to understand of all because
usually when someone has a sample for
plasma or serum it's not linked to a
sequenced infection and vice versa so
it's hard to really get that and since
people have asymptomatic infections you
can never really rule out that they
didn't have a non-variant infection a
few months prior and have antibodies to
that
theoretical wild type version of the
virus we also might have standards for
that as well
so if we look at what we can do in our
surveillance program we're able to
sequence our kov2 genomes using an x-gen
enrichment approach developed similar to
the one for hiv
but specific for sars coke ii again
developed by dr mike berg
and we also have our lead
bioinformaticist support here dr todd
meyer who's developed a pipeline to
process all the information that we get
from sequencing and you can see that by
using this enrichment method
we're now able to get coverage of
genomes going down to about three log
copies per ml which translates to around
a ct of 30. and using these methods we
enable sequence um well over a thousand
specimens to date from all the
geographies that we're working with and
the sequences that we're generating
represent the diversity of circulating
strains primarily in the u.s senegal and
brazil where we've been looking
we have the major variance of concern
alpha beta gamma delta and we have a lot
of other variants of interest included
here that we've characterized in our
program
one study i'd like to highlight that's a
paper that was just accepted last week
in scientific reports describes our work
in senegal where we've characterized
samples from two different ways of the
pandemic the first wave you can see did
not have any variance of concern and had
very little viral diversity there was
one major strain present and that strain
was not the major strain in wave 2 where
we did have variants of concern
interestingly the alpha variant was
present but did not end up being the
predominant strain in this wave in fact
that dark blue one did the
b11420 strain
and if we look at some of these ones
that i've colored in red because they
carry mutations of concern
we see that there are combinations of
mutations that we've seen in other
variants of concern like l452r is
present in epsilon and delta and here
it's in combination with n501y in that
top strain i'm showing here that's 501y
v4a in the a27 lineage and so this
struck as a as unusual because that
combines basically some
a variant that
mutation that's carried in alpha beta
and gamma with a mutation that's found
in delta and epsilon in the spike
protein and so we wanted to get this
information out there by
sharing the sequences as soon as we um
sequence them and sharing this paper and
likewise the one underneath is e44k
which is found in several variants
combined with a new mutation at position
501 and 501t
it's worth noting that these were
present in the second wave of the
pandemic and senegal and that was around
the beginning of this year so these
obviously didn't end up taking over the
world the way delta did
and we're continuing to monitor
how they're spreading
and so we really don't want to be in
this situation again um then and of
course everyone is trying to understand
how we can prevent the next pandemic and
i'd like to end with just a couple of
slides on our abbott pandemic defense
coalition which has been founded as of
this year in 2021
and so our goal is to change the course
of an outbreak before it becomes a
pandemic and the way this program works
is that we have sites that we work with
around the world where every site is
always on the lookout for new pathogens
and the way we do this is we have um
linked in each of our sites around the
world and i'll show where those sites
are in a moment
if someone is tested who has the
symptoms of an infectious disease
and they're negative for all known
pathogens with routine testing
we'll look at that sample with
metagenomic sequencing to see if there's
other viruses or other pathogens present
that we don't know about yet and that's
the first step of this whole process is
identifying a new pathogen and sharing
it through publication process
and then we would be able to be in a
unique position because we're at it to
develop
really quickly some molecular psological
and rapid diagnostic tests and as we've
all seen with the hiv and source code
two pandemics having tests early on are
really key to understanding how much of
a threat a virus or other pathogen
really is
so because we have this network around
the world we could then deploy those
tests to all of those sites to
understand how far a pathogen has
already spread and to understand through
research um whether or not there's any
predictors to disease outcomes and that
can be used to assist the public health
community to make sure we're taking the
appropriate steps
to prevent something and keep everyone
as safe safe as possible
so if we look at
the many sites in our program i showed a
previous map with our surveillance sites
that are shown in blue here for
comparison
we have a total of 12 coalition sites
around the world
and they're all doing the same level of
work where we're looking at specimen
repositories that are collected from
patients of disease of unknown etiology
we're doing all this work in real time
so we're frequently connecting with each
of these groups so we understand what
who's seeing what and what we need to be
doing next together um
we're also looking at bioinformatics
solutions so that we're all using the
same tools to look for these new
pathogens
and this is what it really takes to put
us in the best position possible to
prevent the next pandemic
so that we can be setting the stage to
have informed decisions based on test
results and sequences as early as
possible
and so with that i'd like to thank all
of the many people who have made this
work possible both at abbott and through
our external collaborations and i'd also
like to thank all of the contributors to
sequences in the gsa database
which we frequently use to understand in
our silicon analysis looking at target
regions for starch coke ii
and with that i'd like to thank all of
you for your attention and turn it over
to marie to understand if there's any
questions i can answer
thank you mary for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question is
outside of abbott what other companies
or organizations have this level of a
viral surveillance program
thanks for the question marie um and to
the person who asked it thank you as
well um we actually are the only company
that has a program on this scale for
surveillance of hiv or stars cove 2.
we're really unique in that aspect i
would say we're the only group that
really fits in this category where we're
somewhat academic and somewhat
industry-facing we're kind of in the
middle here and we're the only company
that's really devoted this much to a
program on the scale
thank you
um next question
very interesting presentation do you see
evidence of zoonotic events can
contribute in the evolution of tsar's
cov2 presumably in countries with higher
proportion of rural population
such as senegal is your group developing
collaboration with the us with usda to
gain access to sequence data of sars to
on deer and bats
this is a really fascinating question
because
really that's how viruses get a chance
to evolve right is when they jump into a
different host again um so if they're in
source code two is an animal reservoir
that it hadn't been in before like in a
rural population like um the person who
asked the question mentioned like in in
senegal um that's where we could see new
evolution occurring and then that could
jump back into humans again so we're
definitely keeping an eye on this a lot
of our collaborators at the coalition
sites have programs where they're
looking
in places like farms um for example in
colombia or even senegal
where they're monitoring also vectors
for other diseases like new strains of
dengue for for example
so we definitely are looking for that
kind of
new places for viruses to evolve
and we haven't particularly linked to
usda
but we are in conversations with a lot
of groups within the u.s government
interesting thank you
next question
how are letters assigned to hiv subtypes
it does not appear to be chronological
that's a good question and i know that
the guidelines were established long ago
in the year 2000 um
and at that time they basically laid out
the letters based on what would
currently insisted so
the reason we jump back to l for the
newest one is because it had ended right
before l um before going into the groups
and the groups are mno and p
so um we're following the guidance that
is out there although frankly i couldn't
necessarily speak to the logic behind it
um we're just following the rules that
have been given
okay thank you
next question
what lessons or research tactics have
you adapted into hiv surveillance that
were learned because of sars kovi ii
that's a great question uh because
really we are trying to move faster than
ever before um i would say that in the
past we would sequence a few hundred hiv
genomes and and that would take us a
long time what we've really learned from
stars code 2 is how to increase our
capacity so that we're sequencing
hundreds of months not um hundreds a
year and so the steps we've taken to
improve our processes
in being able to do high throughput
sequencing are something we're taking
now to hiv so that we can sequence more
samples and understand more about what
strains are circulating
thank you
next question
how is abbott using this research to
ensure future generations of diagnostic
assays detect new strains of hiv
this is really
the main reason we're doing this work
because if we don't look at what strains
are circulating we can't we're kind of
blind
to how our tests will need to perform
and so we
are able to take all the sequences that
we've generated over time and build our
tests to mitigate the impacts of viral
diversity knowing that some parts of the
genome are less prone to mutation than
others because they're essential to the
virus and it can't re-um populate if it
has mutations in some regions and so by
looking at what's currently circulating
we can kind of prepare
for what the next strains could be
because we're focusing on the part that
hasn't changed very much up until now
thank you
um it looks like we have one more
question what time for one more question
from the research presented it seems
like new or emerging infectious diseases
evolve very quickly
what other infectious diseases does
abbott monitor
we are keeping pace with um the most
divergent of all viruses out there and
those are
in that category hiv hepatitis b
hepatitis c
um and we've added hepatitis delta as
well we're constantly expanding our list
of pathogens in the program based on how
divergent viruses are out there so if
you look at like the virus that causes
chickenpox that's not a terribly
divergent virus and the sequences are
almost entirely identical so those kinds
of viruses we're not necessarily
tracking um but we're really keeping an
eye on the ones that do have the biggest
impact globally like stars code two and
the ones that have the biggest amount of
viral diversity where we need to make
sure our tests are working
great well thank you mary do you have
any final comments for our audience
well i guess i'd like to just share with
the group that you know my own personal
take is that we're still learning a lot
about starscope 2 and obviously still
learning a lot about hiv but if i think
about all the tools that we have
available now that we didn't have even a
year ago
um i have a lot of hope about what we
can do to protect people going forward
and i'm excited to see what new tools we
might be developing in the coming months
and years so that we can get closer to
zero for these viruses
thank you again mary for your time today
and your presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye